the first wave of series slated to debut
on the disney plus streaming service
promised a return of fan favorites and
big screen staples
bringing some mcu adventure straight to
your living room
but one show in particular is set apart
by an air of mystery and a strange title
what if for quite some time now we've
all been asking two important questions
what if and when well we definitely know
the answer to the latter
on july 8th 2021 marvel dropped the
first official trailer for their new
series
and promised that the show would start
streaming on august 11th
for those without their calendars nearby
that's a wednesday a tradition that was
started with the first episode of loki
back in june
and taking a cue from the god of
mischief all disney plus mtu series will
air on wednesday going forward as for
how many episodes we can expect in 2019
comicbook.com reported that kevin feige
said we're getting 10 episodes for
season 1.
so prepare yourself for the 10 episode
series to kick off on august 11th
i want it come on give me it give me it
give me it come on give me it at the d23
expo in 2019 brian andrews was announced
as a director of what-if
you may not have heard of him but he's
someone with an impressive mcu history
andrews worked in the art department
drawing storyboards for ant-man
doctor strange and avengers end game
what if for marcus first directing
credit in 20 years
since directing the animated series
jackie chan adventures in 2001.
andrews is widely known for his work on
samurai jack which earned him two emmys
for outstanding individual achievement
in animation
in 2005 and 2017. ac
bradley serves as the lead writer and
what if and has a relatively short
resume in the business
bradley wrote one episode of arrow in
2014
in addition to 23 episodes of netflix's
troll hunters
tales of arcadia and 26 episodes of
three below
tales of arcadia as is normal with any
mcu project
kevin feige serves as an executive
producer additionally laura cartman was
tapped to create the score for the what
if episodes the composer has worked on
the critically acclaimed hbo series
loved craft country something mcu fans
were delighted to hear when what if was
announced what's the confirmation that
almost every actor we know and love from
the universe would be voicing the
characters they portray on screen
sadly that doesn't include robert downey
jr who will not be returning with
someone else voicing tony stark instead
and at the time of this video benedict
cumberbatch chris evans and scarlett
johansson
aren't confirmed in the series to voice
their characters of doctor strange
steve rogers and black widow even though
we know those characters are returning
in some form or another
at the same time rumors suggest there
will be an exciting story surrounding
natasha romanov
who ends up voicing these characters
will be quite the surprise when their
respective episodes
air one of the first big reveals that
came with the what-if official
announcement
sdcc 2019 was the identity of the series
narrator
for 10 episodes westworld star jeffrey
wright will lend his voice to the series
azuato the watcher
we got her first look at owatu who's a
mysterious bold being who resembles a
man
in the disney plus featurette expanding
the universe we know from the comics
that owazu is a part of an ancient race
known as the watchers
who simply observe all events throughout
history first appearing in 1963's
fantastic four issue 13
the watchers goal was to help less
evolved species since they were so
technically advanced
after sharing nuclear technology with
the people of another planet
the population decimated themselves
prompting the watchers to never
intervene with civilizations again
wright known for his smooth voice will
voice uh as he watches over these what
could have been events on earth that
involved many of our favorite heroes
the what if comics have been around
since the 70s with the first issue
kicking off in 1977.
what if issue 1 had the subtitle what if
spider-man had joined the fantastic four
and started a successful run of
alternate storylines with famous
characters
the volumes are also narrated by owatu
who at the beginning of the issue
details canonical events readers are
familiar with and then introduces a
what-if moment
that changes the story entirely the rest
of the issue follows that new
alternate story as uatu continues to
narrate what never was
the upcoming television show looks to be
using the basic concept of the comic
series with the added twists of an mcu
focus
expect to see familiar moments from your
favorite marvel movies twisted by one
important change
season 1 of what if will consists of 10
episodes which doesn't seem like enough
room to explore all the possibilities
inherent in the premise
unsurprisingly a second season has
already been confirmed in a 2019
interview with buzzfeed brazil kevin
feige confirmed that the what if series
would go beyond 10 episodes
and he's very excited at what the studio
has put together
i'm very happy that we're doing a
what-if series for disney plus right now
and i've seen most of them we have 10
for season 1.
we're already working on the next 10 for
season 2. this is the first mcu disney
plus series to confirm a second season
and it seems like the show could go even
further past that
as the mcu evolves and more characters
are introduced to us on the big screen
it opens the door to even more what-if
comic story lines the studio can draw
from
here's one thing that we know 100 right
out of the gate
episode one will follow peggy carter
voiced by hayley atwell
feige also told buzzfeed brazil we've
revealed one that is very exciting
we've talked about it for years which is
the one where peggy carter gets a super
soldier serum
and becomes captain carter that's the
very first episode and i'm excited for
people to see that i'm excited to see
the finished version of that
and i'm excited for the world to see it
also detailed in the what if trailers is
a battle between two doctor strangers
this particular episode will follow what
would have happened if there was an evil
sorcerer supreme
but we expect the plot to have a much
more precise point of divergence
which causes the shift in the story we
suspect this particular episode will
pull partly from what if volume 1
issue 18 where doctor strange becomes a
disciple of dormammu
released in 1979 the comic follows an
arrogant stephen strange whose hands are
healed by baron mordo through black
magic
mordo works for the interdimensional
being as his follower and he introduces
strange to the body
the story takes dr strange through a
long journey through self-discovery
which he finds much quicker in the
character's introductory mcu film
before his untimely death in 2020
chadwick boseman participated in what if
by lending his voice to t'challa
there are a few glimpses of the wakandan
in the trailer for the series and it
looks like this retelling will imagine
what would happen if the ravages from
guardians of the galaxy
kidnapped t'challa from earth and not
peter quill instead of becoming black
panther t'challa would take on the role
of star-lord
eventually leading the ravagers
according to illuminati
who star-lord man legendary outlaw
this won't be the only appearance of
t'challa in what if however
kevin feige revealed to emmy magazine
that bozeman came into the studio
and recorded his voice for four
different episodes so we can expect
multiple mcu heroes to pop up more than
once in the animated series
we're also going to be getting a
zombified version of steve rogers
according to release footage taking down
this captain america
terra will be his best buddy bucky
barnes whose mission is to prevent the
spread of this zombie virus
it should be noted that there are no
zombie storylines in the what if comics
but the undead did have a run on the
marvel pages in 2005.
marvel zombies vol 1 was a limited
series that saw the entire superhero
population
zombified and they subsequently ate the
entire human race there have since been
other volumes and spins on the
five-story series
all equally as gruesome while there is
no apparent connection between zombie
cap and living bucky
it'll be exciting to see how this story
plays out on what if
and what event this deviated from in the
duo's history
t'challa won't be the only nod to
wakanda and what if
in the series official trailer we
witness a young killmonger save tony
stark from the missile that blows up in
the original iron man we then watch as
killmonger rides on a rhino and
seemingly fights in a war for wakanda
however this time it appears that
killmonger will be the rightful heir to
the throne
according to screen rant a toy league
has revealed a funko pop figure that
displays the black panther villain as
king of wakanda but it's not just his
new title that's shocking
he's holding a blade in one hand and a
severed head of what's suspected to be
ultron in the other
we can't wait to see how this one plays
out and what scenario could have caused
an instance where killmonger and
ultron came face to face in the mcu
avengers age of ultron and black panther
are set a year apart
with a vengeful ai getting destroyed
before we took a trip to wakanda
killmonger was obviously around at the
time of ultron's creation
just a bit younger and it seems likely
that he sought out the ai once he
learned of its creation
by tony stark and bruce banner if he is
a force for good and a strong
king of wakanda remains to be seen but
it would be a nice twist to see him as a
hero and not a villain
the series official trailer delivered
all sorts of superhero goodness
and while we aren't exactly sure where
the series is headed we're definitely
excited to find out
for example at one point we see thor
fighting off ultron's legions
in las vegas of all places we're
assuming this might be connected to some
interesting merch details that were
leaked in april 2021
according to cbr there's evidently an
official t-shirt and hats that both bear
the image of party thor
while there are more than a handful of
thor stories from the what if comics
nothing seems to fall in line with
whoever the heck party thor is
no matter what this story is about it's
going to be a riot
the trailer also shows us a young shuri
in action
spider-man arriving on the scene ego the
living planet giving us a villainous
screen
and the return of howard the duck gross
on top of all that it appears that klim
barton has somehow received a heavy dose
of gamma radiation as it appears hawkeye
is turning into the hulk
it also looks like loki is leading an
army of asgardians against earth
and perhaps most interestingly there's a
shot of thor black panther
star-lord and gamora holding thanos's
double-bladed sword striking an avenger
style pose
in the middle of a desolated city as for
thanos's favorite daughter we've
definitely heard some interesting
theories about her character
according to the illuminati gamora's
storyline may follow her as she tracks
down her new enemy tony stark
this plot point hasn't been confirmed
yet but if that does indeed pan out that
would be a fascinating twist
last but not least as we previously
mentioned natasha romanov is showing up
in the series alongside some version of
the hulk
and according to another illuminati
report this episode will allegedly see
black widow
as one of the only survivors after
ultron successfully destroyed earth
in 2015. no matter how crazy these
stories seem
what if is going to be one of the most
unique mcu properties
to date check out one of our newest
videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite mcu projects are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one